[Music]
do you ever think about your mortality
does it ever bother you to think that
one day you just won't exist I know
you're not religious but do you think
anything happens when we die or is it
just over no thoughts nothing like that
and if given the choice to live longer
in an artificial body would you take
that or not thanks Josh fabulous
question yes I think about mortality
continually men I won't say constantly
but every day so I like to just make
give you something to think about if you
live to be eighty two and seven weeks
depends on leap years as the exact
number of weeks you get thirty thousand
days on our thirty thousand when you're
in kindergarten thirty thousand sounds
like a lot almost unimaginably big
number when you are my age I'm 61 you
start to see that thirty thousand really
isn't that many and to show you it's not
that many I encourage you to imagine a
National Football League stadium they
typically hold way more than seventy
thousand people certainly way more than
sixty thousand people so imagine sitting
in a different seat every day of your
life and watching your life take place
down on the field
imagine this sit in a different seat
every day day to day it looks about the
same right but with thirty thousand you
don't get halfway around halfway around
it sucks man so that's why it's
important to do your best to live your
life as best as you can every day this
doesn't mean you become a hedonist and
just have a joyride every day you're
working to big goals but no one
appreciate that
everybody is going to die I have never
met anyone who's not going to die I've
never met anyone who's of a certain age
who's not already dead
it sucks now here's the evidence for why
I don't believe in an afterlife it would
be a fine thing if you could if I could
have the capabilities athletically that
I had when I was say 23 with a life
experience in intellect that I have
right now it'd be fantastic and then
live forever I say bring it on but my
beloved grandmother who was brilliant
didn't have that happen she faded away
losing her faculties as she went people
my age have a lot of grandparents and
parents who are not as sharp certainly
not as athletically capable or
physically capable as they were when
they were younger and so watching
ourselves die is to me overwhelming
evidence that there is no life after
death as certainly no it doesn't seem to
be any reason to think that when you die
you go back to your optimum age at your
optimum athletic ability in your optimum
intellectual sharpness and if it turns
out that that's true that you do die and
have all this intellectual sharpness and
athletic ability cool
bring it on that'll be great but what
would you do differently what would you
do differently if you knew for sure that
you were going to be immortal when you
died somehow would you start committing
crimes would you jump off a cliff so
that you can hurry to your immortality
optimal state I just don't think so
instead the finite length of our life is
what drives us it's what makes us go and
it's what makes you try to
accomplish things or or decide to have
kids or not have kids or decide to live
in another on another cut in another
country on another continent or not or
decide how to invest your money or what
you're going to do with your resources
all this is driven by the the limited
length of life we have so furthermore if
evolution is in fact how the world works
and it absolutely sir seems to be from
my point of view the one of the
fundamental things about evolution that
is so troubling is this whole idea of
survival of the fittest that's really a
19th century usage a British usage of
that expression fit test it doesn't mean
that you're able to do the most
weightlifting or run the fastest 1500
meters or something it means you fit in
the best
in the troubling troubling consequence
of this is you don't have to be perfect
or super person you just have to be good
enough from an evolutionary standpoint
you just have to be good enough to pass
your genes on after that evolution if it
were an entity doesn't really care about
you man you had your kids your genes are
passed on and you expire you lose your
faculties as you run out of steam and
that's just how it is
evolution certain diseases catch up with
you certain autoimmune problems show up
certain viruses and bacteria parasites
get you Nature doesn't care you were
good enough and so I encourage you to
live your life as best you can every day
and as far as putting my brain in an
electronic receptacle for all time it
sounds great but I will evaluate it on a
case-by-case basis do you want to be
stuck in an Apple product the rest of
your life or do you want to be stuck in
a micro
off product that's a tough call
I'm sure books will be written we'll see
great question carry on
[Music]